[car horns blaring]
[phone ringing]
[jungle wildlife calls]
OPERATOR (THROUGH PHONE):
Prepaid call from.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH
PHONE): Joe Exotic.
OPERATOR (THROUGH
PHONE): An inmate
at the Grady County Jail.
This call is also subject to
being recorded or monitored.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH
PHONE): Hello?
Hi, how are you doing?
Mariana here.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH PHONE): Hi.
Thank you so much
for calling me.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER):
It all started
with an online reality show.
Hey, I'm Joe Exotic,
The gay, gun-carrying
redneck with a mullet.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER): Before
Netflix's hit series,
"Tiger King" made Joe
Exotic famous worldwide.
FILMMAKER: He was like a
mythical character living out
in the middle of
[beep] Oklahoma.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER):
But lost in the hype
surrounding the series--
MAN: So Joe said, will you
go to Florida and what?
HIT-MAN: Kill that [beep] lady.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER):
--was a serious discussion
about private tiger
ownership in America.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH PHONE):
I've been in the tiger industry
for a little over 20 years now.
Probably the largest
breeder and handler
of tigers in the United States.
MARIANA: So give me just a
sense of the tiger community,
cow petting zoos, and all that.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH PHONE):
Well, you're getting the world
to pay for your hobby.
Yeah.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH
PHONE): At least
that we have man enough to
say, look, I own a roadside zoo
and I breed tigers.
I'm stuck trying to
figure out why the hell
I'm in jail, for first of all.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER):
To be clear,
Joey Exotic is behind bars
because he was convicted
of the attempted murder
for hire of Carole Baskin
as well as 17 wildlife crimes.
CARNEY ANNE NASSER: In the words
of the judge at Joe Exotic's
sentencing, Joe is a master
manipulator who is engaged in,
quote, "systematic trafficking"
of tigers and other big cats.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER): Yet,
critics of "Tiger King"
say the series celebrated
Joe, while largely overlooking
his treatment of animals.
CARNEY ANNE NASSER:
Joe is not a folk hero.
He is somebody who, for
decades, profited off
of the exploitation
and abuse of animals.
And Joe is finally
where he belongs.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER):
So why would
you want to breed a tiger?
Well, in the US roadside
zoos can bring in big money
by offering cow petting
experiences to tourists.
JOHN GOODRICH: They raise
tiger cubs, so that people can
pay money and take
selfies, so they
have to have this
constant supply
of these little tiny tiger cubs
between one and four months.
So there's just this
huge breeding operation,
but the key thing here is
that after the cubs are about
four-months-old, they're
too dangerous for the public
to handle.
They need to be
handed off somewhere.
And often, I don't
think we really
know what happens to them.
MARIANA (VOICEOVER):
To understand the scope
of the issue, "National
Geographic" magazine reviewed
Joe Exotic's records
from 2010 to 2018,
and learned that his
zoo traded nearly
200 tigers with dozens of other
private owners across America.
Breeders, like Joe,
are one of the reasons
that they are now an
estimated 5 to 10,000
tigers in the United States.
With less than 4,000
tigers left in the wild,
there are now more tigers
living in captivity in the US
than there are
wild tigers living
in the rest of the world.
JOE EXOTIC (THROUGH PHONE): If
something's endangered, hell,
we need to start
breeding it, do we not?
Is that not what the purpose
of it being endangered is?
We need more of.
[ominous music playing]